one of the things that we've spoken
about privately that we haven't yet
spoken about publicly is victimhood and
James Cantor came on the show he's a sex
researcher he gave me this really
interesting quote I wanted you to react
to shifting from aiding victims to
aiding everyone who claims victimhood
has led to an awful lot of charlatanism
shifting from doing good to looking good
has led to an awful lot of virtue
signaling their interaction is now
Western culture at least online what do
you think about that I think it's true
and if you think about how you know I
believe people respond to
incentives that's fundamentally the
driving force of all human behavior
we're respond to
incentives if you incentivize victimhood
you're going to get victims uh and I
think online is really the the shift
that happens because the online World
rewards it and it also allows people to
fake victimhood in a way that in person
you can't really like if you see someone
living in a massive house you go well
you may be invict in some ways but
you're actually well taken care of here
but online you can create any Avatar you
want and that Avatar can be projected
onto the online space from a mansion
that's kind of where we are yeah the
fact that our opinions are more
important than our deeds and our words
are scrutinized while our actions are
done in private you know how many people
have we seen over the last few years
Ellen degenerous lizo uh who's that late
night host that just got popped for
apparently being Jimmy Fallon I think uh
allegedly has these people that
outwardly are supposed to be Champion
for the underclass like I'm supporting
women of all sizes or I'm supporting
people that have different sexual
orientations or I do the whatever and
then you find out behind the scenes that
they can't even treat a PA with
dignity I don't know it it seems to me
like being someone who outfront prozes
about standing up for the for the under
class is almost becoming a red flag to
go I probably should scrutinize what's
actually going on behind the scenes here
when I was a standup comedian in the
comedy world there's a golden rule of
this the more a comedian talks about how
he's a male feminist on stage the
sleazier he is backstage that's it's
like a golden rule never fails always
the same so anyone who goes on stage and
talks about how brilliant they are
they're always always always Sleazy and
evil behind the scenes it's just how it
works and I think it's actually it's a
kind of compensat mechanism people who
are hiding a bunch of [__] have to go
out and then pretend to be something
they're not the morality sort of stands
on the shoulders of this
performative [__] is there a
solution to this is there a way that we
can scrutinize given that people's deeds
and their actions and their words and
their opinions are always going to be
far
apart I think that we are living through
a digital Revolution for which we're not
prepared uh naturally that's what
Revolution is right it's a change in in
the Paradigm of how we exist so I think
that 10 15 20 years from now we will
look back at the way we use social media
now and be horrified by it you'll you'll
be a little bit like you know tobacco
companies promoting cigarettes as a
healthy thing to do and then we'll be
like whoa whoa whoa this was actually
causing a lot of damage so I think the
answer to this is is a healthier
relationship with the online World in
particular uh My Hope Is that we get
past this stage and work out how to use
all of that stuff better I see it in
myself like the way I use social media
now is very different to the way I would
have used it even two years ago so um
I'm much more responsible with the way I
use it and I mean in terms of my own
life in terms of how much time I spend
on there and what I do but also in terms
of the way I act on social media because
I am trying to be more responsible in
what I say you know it's very easy and I
think especially on on X or Twitter
whatever you want to call it
to get clicks and I know exactly how to
do that which is dunk on somebody and I
spend less and less on my time doing
that now because I just I don't think
that makes the world better I don't
think it makes me better there's very
rare it's very rare on Twitter to have
someone uh break the fourth wall and say
that was out of order you're not allowed
to say that everybody plays this sort of
permanent game of sardonic tennis right
here's some Blas comment about how you
suck as some smart snipe back at what
you said and oh I hit it back across the
net with something else no one actually
says what they should say which is
that's [__] out of order and then
you're approved if you do this is why
this is why it's disincentivized this is
coming back to the point about
incentives social media rewards certain
types of behavior and punishes others so
if you're the guy that says maybe we
shouldn't you know pile on this person
if your team is doing the piling on
you're like the the one who's not
willing do you know what I mean you're
not willing to join in with stoning
somebody and that's why you're a loser
that's the the model that we operate in
so being responsible is disincentivized
yeah the um I love this idea that an
absurd ideological belief or an extreme
ideological belief is a show of fty to
your own side and a threat display to
the other right and the more absurd or
extreme the belief the
more likely it is that your own side can
trust you and that the other side should
fear you do you know what I mean that if
it's if you have to put reason and
Sensibility and common decency to one
side in order to like here I am holding
my hand in the air for whatever the
current thing is your own side sees you
as a reliable Ally and the other side
sees you as a formidable foe mhm it's
Tribal mechanics but multiplied by a
thousand correct because it's online
with everyone scrutinizing you yeah and
so you have these weird pathologies like
you've got and it's not not a comment on
him personally but you've got like a guy
who lives in Malaysia commenting on
American culture War issues and getting
like millions and millions of views for
his commentary and whatever and he just
go I see what you're doing there but are
you actually contributing to anything do
you know what I mean uh because it's
just flaming Fanning the Flames of
whatever is going on um and I see that
as a you know like I say it's a period
it's a transitionary period I hope that
we get to a point where we start to use
social media in a different way and
actually you know this is an unpopular
thing to say but I don't envy the big
Tech
Executives uh because it's a really hard
job because the on the one hand you
incentivized to encourage engagement and
on the other
hand the engagement is achieved by
amplifying anger and Division and all of
these things so I I hope we can work
that out as a as a society how do we
move forward with social media what
about the victimhood side of things then
you know like it's kind of it's almost
like old Trope to talk about snowflakes
and all this sort of [__] was like
you know five year ago culture Warrior
horeshit but the underlying Dynamic is
still there that we've got this sort of
tyranny of the minority in some regards
that fragility is something to Aspire
toward or at least it's something which
is rewarded in a variety of different
ways what's your sort of conception and
and framework of this with a little bit
more perspective that we've got now well
I'm going to be speaking at ARC Jordan
Jordan's thing later this year and one
of the things I want to talk about is
that I think everyone's embraced this
now we all now do it I feel like those
of us who've been concerned about
wokeness have sort of got into that
place where we are like I'm a victim
I've been canceled I've been this and
I've been that and I think it's time
actually for us to step into our power
now and go okay well we've created these
New Media organizations we've created
alliances we've created Community we've
created things and the question really
for us is now we know what we're against
but not enough people are willing to say
what are we for exactly and that's cuz
it's much harder to do but that is the
mission now it's how do you get past
woke anti-woke into the future and the
future has to be about offering people a
better alternative to that victimhood uh
because it's it's more rewarding for the
individual to to see themselves in that
way I think um and this is you know this
is why Jordan Peterson was so successful
when he broke through because he was
saying to people take responsibility and
I think we all actually now are in a
position where we have to say it to
ourselves yes
the right-wing snowf flaker sphere that
nobody really ever talks about I'm
pretty sure that you hate that even more
than you hate leftwing snowflake asphere
like it's it's
so yeah the using the callout culture to
say this is something that shouldn't be
happening this is
pedestalize about that that remain
extremely unanswered like where do you
get meaning and purpose in your life now
in a society that has fewer and fewer
children in which young people are
delaying adulthood longer and longer and
longer um where do you get meaning and
purpose exactly for now for some people
that's you know online activism but
actually how fulfilling that is I don't
know so the big questions remain
unanswered and perhaps increasingly so
actually I think there may be May there
could well be an argument that 80 years
ago people had way more meaning and
purpose readily available to them at you
know just through the course of normal
life you know get married have kids
whatever now obviously that wasn't
universally and available to everybody
Etc but I think in the modern world
actually way more people are lost they
don't know what they're supposed to do
exactly so in the past we had a kind of
like set trajectory you're supposed to
follow which hurt some people because it
wasn't the trajectory for them but when
you take away all trajectory then
everybody's lost and I think a lot of
people are in that position now so we
and and as I say I think it's way harder
to think about what the positive vision
of the future is but that I think is the
task now that's the mission that's you
know what is it that if you think
wokeness is stupid and dangerous and
harmful which I do well what do you
think in addition to that what do you
think beyond that what is it that you
think people ought to do if they ought
not to be victims what ought they to
think about with their lives right um
and that's a very difficult question uh
that I have more questions than answers
about actually it's way easier to
identify problems than propose Solutions
right and you almost see this on the
internet that if somebody identifies a
problem it's kind of hard to criticize a
criticism it's possible Right but it's
way easier to criticize a proposal and
it's almost like a defense mechanism
that people have to frontload or front
run avoiding the criticism that they
know will become will be incoming you
know it's the caveat it's like I'm not
saying that we don't need to care about
such and such and I'm not saying that
this isn't a big deal but maybe we need
to think about this thing it's almost
like a a conceptual equivalent of that
yes and I find myself doing that all the
time fortifying with caveat all the time
man because I think the the other aspect
of the online the way the communication
happens online is like if you make a
statement a generalized statement you
might say exercise is good for you and
somebody will be like yeah but what if
you've got an ear injury and before you
know it like you hate disabled people
like that's kind of how the conversation
happens but we I think when when we stop
being able to make normative statements
everything else breaks down right we
have to be able to say for most people
most of the time pairing up with someone
of the sex that they are attracted to
and and building a life together is
better than not doing that we have to be
able to say that without the one person
who was in an abusive relationship what
about me right yes we understand you but
we're talking about the 95% of people
right uh and you feel free not to go
along with whatever we're putting on the
table it's like if we put a menu of
things on the table you don't have to
eat everything no one is making you eat
the gluten it's the Ricky jaas guitar
lessons thing right I want guitar
lessons so I think think we have to be
able to
say all other things being equal family
is good well this is the the tyranny of
the minority I [__] love that phrase
I think it's so smart to optimize for
the edges of the bell curve rather than
the middle and as you said before there
is a it is important to recognize that
there are people who fall outside of the
the Norms of normality and that they
need some care as well and if you didn't
have that sufficiently broad perspective
view these people would just fall
through the and that's [__] [__] and
nobody wants that to happen but when you
optimize for that you actually end up if
you were to net out what happens you end
up with more suffering because you
neglect all of the [__] fat bit of
the middle of the distribution that's
right and we've we've stopped being able
to make that point because we and also I
think a phrase that I came across and I
didn't come up with this but somebody
was saying to me the other day that we
live in a world of trade-off
denialism what's that mean every
decision has trade-offs it has positives
and negatives and if you go well we
should do this and someone goes yeah but
what about the thing that and then you
can never really acknowledge it's like
the climate catastrophe right no one
wants to talk about the fact that many
of the solutions that are being proposed
would be worse than the
problem so it's like if you say anything
about how we're approaching that issue
you are denying that climate change is
real or you are denying that it's a
problem or you denying that we should
address it no I just think you are idea
of how to fix it is stupid right and
we've lost the ability to have that
conversation as well and I think we
really need to reintroduce that it's one
of the things I talked about in my Ox
speech which I think is why it did well
is because people want oh yeah all right
because because if we just do the stuff
that we're being told we need to do
that's actually worse and that sort of
opened it up I think we've totally
forgotten that every there are no
Solutions only trade-offs my favorite
quote ever from Thomas Soul yeah it's
lovely and that the difference between
maximizing and satisficing from
behavioral economics is an interesting
one so maximizing is everything must be
100 100 100 100 satisficing is hitting
an acceptable level across everything
and what the satisficing allows you to
do is allows you to iser rate much more
quickly and as you say you can imagine
you can do it in your own life it's like
how many times have you done it GNA go
away on holiday with the misses and
we're going to have a [__] Airbnb or
booking.com favorite list with 30 hotels
or 30 places in and by the time that you
get down to choosing them the choice has
been made for you because all of the
nice ones have gone and you're now two
days before you leave right that's
maximizing and you're so stressed you
need the holiday [__] yeah it was awful
you didn't even enjoy the experience of
it as well yeah yeah I understand man
like you know people feel like they're
being left behind they feel like life is
happening to them or happening for other
people and they're not a part of it and
I I get that like I you know [__]
it's disquieting life is going on my
friends are moving on the world is
changing and I'm all
confused but I suppose this sort of
information ecosystem conversation which
you guys have had a good bit and I've
had twice over the last few weeks first
with Sam Harris and then with Eric
Weinstein what do you make of this like
the heterodox sphere has its problems
the Legacy Media sphere has its
problems independent creators that just
get to [__] post usly on Twitter and
Reddit also I like very unreliable
what's the do you think about this like
how all of this comes together and how
you move forward through it I I see a
lot of problems with New Media too I
mean and I've said this from day one in
terms of what we do at trigonometry it's
uh we don't have a budget to employ a
bunch of people to do extensive research
on things or to do factchecking for us
so we can't do certain things that the
mainstream media can do and should do
the problem is the mainstream media
isn't doing it either right uh but
there's a there's a really important
role for the mainstream media I just
wish they'd play that role uh but you
know I I think where I agree with Sam
even though I disagree with him on coid
and and to some extent well to a large
extent Trump and all those things is
there not everything can be fixed on a
podcast that is absolutely true there
are certain things that are a matter of
research and deeper study and it it's
not not everything can be sorted out in
thre hour conversation between two
podcasters it's that's not how how that
works and I think uh New Media has its
own problems um it over rewards Charisma
it over rewards passion it it massively
under rewards any attempts to uh cling
to truth it encourages people to go off
in the pursuit of the most uh exciting
in take and Truth isn't always exciting
yeah you know so I think the truth is we
need a vibrant ecosystem in which all of
these different pieces play their own
different roles um which is why I'm in
favor of Maximum freedom because that's
where you get everybody doing their
thing and then you know over time people
this people who want wholesome content
if you like when it comes to facts or
information or whatever can seek it out
because people aren't stupid they they
they can see through um they will see
through someone being super charismatic
or whatever they'll get to a point where
they go actually what I'd like to do is
have a look at what different sources
are saying about this and make up my own
mind you saw with Co you know the
mainstream media really suppressed a lot
of very legitimate points of view uh a
lot of important information but then
you get the response to that which is to
go quite far off the other end and I've
ended up somewhere what I hope is a kind
of reasonable Middle Ground between
those two positions there's a really
great blog post by by Ginder Bogle gosub
stack.com one of my favorite writers why
you are probably in NPC and he frames
out five different types of NPC and the
the most obvious two you know like sort
of the mainstream NPC and the contrarian
NPC he makes this really great point
which is that the contrarian NPC is no
deeper thinking than the mainstream NPC
they're just the inversion of it yes and
he uses the the line of um being a black
sheep might make you different but
you're still a sheep and and
that Allure this sort of Romance of
being the independent thought leader
maker sense maker person I understand
why it happens but yeah reflexive
contrarianism is no more nuanced than
reflective belief of the hemony yes and
um you know I don't judge people for
that because I I think that's an element
of my thinking you know a kind of I
think it's very understandable the
disillusionment with the way the
institutions have been captured or have
been corrupted or perverted or what
whatever it is that's happened to them
um it is natural that that would produce
an equal and opposite
reaction um I encourage myself and other
people to go beyond that I try as best I
can and to go okay well we're reacting
to this this is how we're behaving
what's the actual what's the actual
truth because that's where we started we
started from the position that we cared
about the truth that's why so annoyed
with the mainstream uh can we can we
find somewhere in between those two
positions that actually is an attempt to
find that truth um and it's it's the
case with everything you know we've had
a bunch of we just had the the co-found
of Navara media on trigonometry the
far-left
YouTube or not maybe not farle is it
kind of corista supporting kind of
people and others because we're trying
to speak to different people from
different uh places and really get to to
what the bottom of is of different
issues because those perspectives are
valuable too one of the things that Sam
brought up on the episode with me was
his Infamous Twitter clip with you what
was the experience of that particular
180 seconds Catching Fire
like you know I felt terrible when that
happened really really terrible
because I've never been on the end of a
Twitter [__] storm to that extent but it
it's not pleasant no matter how
strong-minded you are whatever there's a
reason that Rogan always says don't read
the comments right like like the great
man Joseph Stalin says quantity has a
quality all of its
own so there's only certain number of
negative comments you can ignore until
just the volume of [__] becomes
overwhelming so my primary concern
actually not I don't know Sam well but
uh was for his well-being actually I
just I just worried how he would
experience that more than anything that
was my concern because our approach is
always about giving a guest and
opportunity to reveal themselves in the
best light possible and for some people
that light shines very brightly and can
burn um but that's not our intention we
never go into an interview with a desire
to out somebody or expose somebody it's
not a got you it's not a got you so I
was worried about him and I emailed him
straight away just to you know check up
on him and and you know also we didn't
put that clip out we could have done
because we obviously understood that it
was a controversial thing he said and
actually most people don't know this but
that was not the most controversial
thing he said in that interview in my
opinion we talked about coid on locals
which was the payall section of the
interview and what he said there I found
quite what did he say I don't remember
the wording and people have to go and
watch it but it was you know I came away
from that thinking that you know he's
overestimating the threat and as a
result of that is prep to do some pretty
drastic things or or demand drastic
things to be done um so first and
foremost as somebody who interviews
people for a living I was concerned for
him but I also felt that you know what
he said was wrong I didn't agree with it
um
and I I I my view on it is that if you
overestimate the nature of the threat
all else follows and I think on Trump
and that that is where Sam in my opinion
is is that's why he's doing what he's
doing and saying what he's saying
because if I thought Trump was as bad as
TR Sam thinks it'd be very tempting to
think along the lines that Sam thinks
along and likewise with Co if I thought
this was like
Ebola that
spreads I'd also be you know we should
also be honest you know the conversation
people like well there's never ever ever
any reason for the government to mandate
vaccines and I broadly agree with that
unless the disease is really like
dangerous and deadly I said this at the
beginning of coid like imagine that the
disease had 100% mortality rate for all
women or it was 100% mortality rate for
all people under the age of 10 there'd
be some people who'd support it well
yeah but I I think that the the
fundamentally it came down to a risk and
reward equation and most people
considered that the risk of getting Co
was not greater than the risk of either
getting the vaccine or of opening up
mandated vaccines as a pathway overall
right and it's just where do you sit on
this equation there's lots of other
things but broadly I think it's where do
you sit on this equation
and Sam I completely agree with him that
I think
CO as an event was like the worst kind
of vaccine that we could have given our
epidemiology our medical system the view
of vaccines over over all vaccine
skepticism at large I bet has gone
through the [__] roof it has it has
have you had a look at this yeah of
course it has I know anecdotally just
speaking to people how much that's
that's the case yeah so if we are to
have something that comes around the
next time and it does kill [__] all
children under 10 or all women or
whatever the [__] it's got some
incubation period of 28 days and a
mortality of
40% it's just a scop it's another scop
this is CLA Schwab doing it again this
is the WF and it's like oh God like
that's that's it literally would have
been better if Co hadn't happened right
yeah sure enough we can get masks out of
the way more quickly and we've got like
some some inefficiency in in the system
we're opened up but if you were to look
at coid as a like operational logistical
vaccine our response to it failed us way
worse than if we'd never got it at all
and we got a vaccine injury from coid
yes yes we did and and I also think the
one thing that is sort of in explicably
neglected in all of this
is I'd really like to know where Co came
from I'd really like to know don't you
think that's important don't you think
we should know where it came from
because there are some credible
assertions about its Origins that would
suggest that we may have another
pandemic soon um is that right haven't
seen this well
if this came from a lab in Wuhan because
of gain of function
research and we not willing to be honest
about that and gain of function research
continues why wouldn't we have another
pandemic I never looked into this much I
know that uh Sam had Matt Ridley and
somebody else somebody else on his show
we've had Matt on to talk about this as
well okay Co yeah and the truth is we
don't know yeah uh but I I'm using the
kind of the smell test here because I
grew up in a in a in a communist
Society um and what communist societies
do when there is something and all
societies do this to a large extent
because people don't like to to expose
their own flaws and no one wants to be
like oh I was responsible for killing
millions of people you know but they
will cover it up in a way that you know
that is proper and Matt actually gave
this example of there was a leak
somewhere in the Soviet Union which was
a radioactive leak I think or maybe it
was a biological uh and they covered up
for ages and then you know when the
Soviet Union collapsed we finally find
out no no it was actually a leak so if
this is a product of uh gain of function
research getting out into the real world
which is credible that there's there's
very credible assertions about that the
world needs to know and this type of
research needs to
end but if we are unwilling to have that
conversation honestly and do the proper
investigations which would be difficult
because the CCP wouldn't want that and
on top of that you've got all this other
[__] about how it's racist and all
of that uh we've got a problem so the I
I think my worry with everything
everything that's happened with Co is
not only have we not learned the lessons
I feel like like you said we've got a
vaccine injury from the experience and
everyone is sort of stuck in their
corner and like Sam said to you
everyone's got their own facts about it
now
correct um that's that's a
problem it's interesting what you said
about the felt sense of being in the
blast radius of Sam's online experience
I noticed
it someone called it Sam Harris's World
embarrassment tour because he did my
show he did Steven's show and he did Tom
bil's
Show and I don't know man like there
seems to be
something it's almost like there was
resentment sat on the internet latent
resentment sat on the internet waiting
for Sam to [__] up and then he did a
thing oh maybe maybe it's right I don't
think it was personal that was my the
reason I paused there I don't think it
was personal to Sam I think particularly
on his Trump comment ments there are a
lot of people who were like this is what
we always knew the Trump haters think
deep inside and Sam was willing to
vocalize it which is I don't care how
big the transgressions are on the other
side I don't care what Hunter Biden has
done I don't care what Joe Biden's done
no matter what they do it can never be
as bad as orange man bad and that's sort
of how he came across and so the people
who who fell gasl this entire time
about um you know the overestimation of
the threat of trump they they were
Vindicated in that moment and I think
Sam just caught him was caught in the
Rage of people feeling like the kind of
like the perfect timed storm with the
perfect Pebble in the perfect river that
directed it yeah yeah yeah yeah it's so
interesting man you know we I had this
conversation with a a fitness influencer
called Sarah Safari in La a couple of
weeks ago uh I'd be interested to get
your thoughts on on this I think it's
analogous to the Sam situation a lot of
people especially right of Center say
things like you can't judge somebody on
just one thing that they
say yet when it came to a sixpack of Bud
Light being sent to Dylan mulany by some
marketing intern somewhere deep in the
annals of the Anisa Bush thing or
millerite release one video the
millerite felt a little bit more
produced it's probably gone through a
few more layers but largely I just
wondered I thought it was interesting
that
the charity that a lot of people right
of Center ask to be given to their
commentators or you know their Champions
that are cancelled for taken out of
context points there was that uh Rosanne
bar bit with theovon where she made a
joke about the Jews which was the most
egregious clipping that I've ever seen
from anything ever the end of a three
minute long bit and they took the final
30 seconds and put it up as if it was
representative of the whole thing it was
so [__]
bad but I did notice nobody decided to
use that same idea about well hang on a
second maybe maybe this is just one
small Department in one small corner of
one small Brand's marketing push and
they gave this person who is very
unpopular on the internet a sixpack of
budlight and before you know it Kid
Rock's got an AR-15 pointed at a few
cases of your drink what do you think
about
so I think I would separate those two
out so Sam I think is that point applies
very much and this is what the angle I'm
coming up from and by the way we're
about to go back to America and we'll
interview Sam the sequel so we'll see
how that works out I'm looking forward
to it uh but with Sam what I felt was
for me I don't know if it's true of
other people but for me Sam has a lot of
credit in the bank with me and so and so
I felt that while I strongly disagree
with what he said I think that was clear
in the interview um he has enough credit
in the bank with me that I'm willing to
have a lot of understanding and a lot of
Grace with him and I I like and what I
would say as well is you know we were
having a lot of tech issues on the day
that we interviewed Sam and he sat there
for like a good hour while we were
trying to scrambling to get the
microphones to work and he was the most
decent human being that we've had on the
show
you see who someone really is when the
cameras aren't rolling that seemed to me
like a really important thing that other
people obviously wouldn't have seen so
um I have a lot of time for Sam and
respect for him I don't have the same
relationship with Dy
malany and I also think you haven't
taken a world of wisdom from Dylan
milany over the last you'll be surprised
man you'll be surprised and so um I
think look Dylan m is a symbol in to
many people like Sam is a symbol to many
people for different things but I I
think it's a slightly different issue
because you I don't know if you saw but
immediately after the the D mulany
Controversy the marketing executive who
was responsible for this there was there
was a video of her talking to I think a
reporter about the thinking
behind what the idea there was it seemed
a little bit more thought out it was
thought out and her her angle was our
our customers of [__] that was her angle
a [__] yeah what's a [__] customer well
it was just it's just these guys who've
got like a you know oldfashioned sense
of humor and they don't do you know what
I mean like we're going to educate our
customers and I'm like you sell beer
that's not your job sell them the
[__] beer and shut up yeah right um
and look the trans issue for reasons I
actually think are quite understandable
and obvious is the lightening Rod of our
time um so I'm not surprised that that
caused the reaction that it did and and
I understand understand it I I I do
think and I said I wrote a substack on
this at the time um that perhaps the
giving so much attention to it is what
prompts these Brands to to go down this
route obviously with Dylan malania
backfired for sure it's a role of the
dice for attention it's a role of the
dice for attention that I don't think
they'd considered and I think that
executive ended up being fired I do
understand why people got as fired up
about as they did because your rewarding
behavior that a lot of people would feel
is the wrong Behavior to reward in the
public eye Dylan M MH but that woman is
one lady maybe maybe in her interview
with the reporter she said this went all
the way up and the director C the
[__] Chief marketing officer or
whatever was involved in this but if it
wasn't the
case I don't think if if it turned out
that it was one small group in in the
corner as I like guessed or whatever I
don't think that the internet would have
given budlight any more leeway I don't
think they would have said we need to
separate the art and the artist here you
know they've made beer for three decades
for however [__] long it's been
around and maybe maybe it's righty maybe
it it shows their woke bonafides it
shows that they're the
man-hating like left leaning bluehead
cooks that they always
were but I don't know like it seems like
a lot of the time people want it's a
it's a smart idea to be able to say
Rogan has been in a few controversies
over the last few years most people said
I have faith that you're telling me this
is the tip of the
iceberg I've seen the whole Iceberg
right I know that there is nothing
lurking deep down in the depths massive
Advantage he has is he's published like
5,000 hours of content over the last
decade which means that you have a
pretty good body of evidence that sits
on the other side of the scale Bud Light
you don't know much about what's going
on inside of the marketing department
but I just thought it was interesting I
thought that maybe this is a time where
it would be illustrative and you should
be careful about trans transgressing
rules that you want to be enforced so if
you want the don't judge somebody by one
single occurrence rule to be enforced
and then you don't enforce
it that as you said before that tit
fortat game it opens up what they did it
say is playground mentality I understand
what you mean but I think I disagree
actually I think the reason that people
uh were as upset about as they are is
while it's these are different companies
the sense is imagine it wasn't just
Rogan who said something but it was
Chris Williamson and trigonometry and
all the other podcasters who do what we
do all at one point said the same thing
and then there was yet another example
of a podcast say so when you look at the
Gillette M toxic masculinity ad if you
look at all the other instances where
corporations put Pride flags all they
replace their brand with not in the
Middle East not well obviously not yeah
they do Russia they can't do it in
Russia I doubt it I doubt it I can't
imagine why in Mother Russia gay has you
yeah exactly so I think what people felt
was here again we've got a corporation
just absolutely taking the piss
lecturing the ordinary public and
thrusting these very Niche issues onto
what is a very very like normal
household beer and you just can't escape
this [__] that's what I think people
feel kind of a straw that broke the
camel's back
B Corporation overall that's interesting
CU what I was doing was I was taking
budlight as a individual instance on its
own what you're saying is this is more
endemic of a broader Trend among big
corporations well broadly speaking if
you think about what the anti-woke
narrative is the anti-woke narrative is
and I agree with very large part of it
is that most of the major institutions
whether that be media whether that be
the Civil Service whether that be uh the
political systems the parties the
uh the corporations the education system
they've all been captured or corrupted
or through some other mechanism become
uh the projectors of a certain world
viiew onto the public who do not share
that world viw and so when you
see the toxic masculinity Gillette ad
which is like hey you know you you're
you're a man you're a piece of [__] buy
a Razer
you you know hey you're a piece of [__]
Buy beer Etc it sort of builds up to a
point like why is everyone telling me
I'm a piece of [__] um and it gets old
and you know and I actually you know
particularly this anti- mascul anti-
masculinity narrative that you see
everywhere in movies uh in advertising
in in all sorts of different genres uh I
think it's really really dangerous
because if you think about Gillette ads
in the '90s you were a bit younger than
me I don't know if you remember them but
the best a man can get and it's like
some blonde hot chicken like a whatever
she's likeed on shoulder actually that
wasn't the '90s Gillette ads the '90s
Gillette ads were a bunch of men being
healthy masculinity it was uh a man
putting his tie on as he holds his baby
up before he's going to work he was a
man uh hugging his son on his way to his
wedding he was a man protecting his wife
or you know it was a it was a healthy
view of and relationships and men and
women and so on um and I I sort of say
you know healthy masculinity is the '90s
Gillette ads that's what it looks like
um men being responsible men in
relationships with women being
respectful being kind but also being
strong looking after their children
teaching younger versions of men how to
be men Etc right um and I understand why
people men and women are [__] tired
really really tired of this idea that
men are bad and evil my wife who complet
I always say my wife is completely
apolitical and as a result of that
extremely
based right like she hates this [__] and
I can't tell you how many women I speak
to who are very very tired of men being
demonized in this way and so I well
especially given that a lot of those
women will have sons and they want their
partner to be good and healthy they
don't want them to be feeble you know um
so I actually I understand the push back
against that I really do and I think
it's necessary
yeah the I mean I've spent a lot of
time talking about modern masculinity
and and the challenges that everybody is
facing what do you think like looking at
it from your perspective growing up
where you did in a communist country
coming here
13 remembered it coming here at 13
what's what do you think the
conversation around modern masculinity
from both sides of defense is missing
like what what don't they understand
about being a man in 2023 and the
challenges and the way that the culture
sees them I think we should zoom out
more even more than that and ask the
question what is it that we want as a
society and I piss both sides of the
spectrum off by saying what I'm about to
say which is any ideology and I mean any
ideology that pits men against women or
women against men is toxic and damaging
and dangerous and unhealthy and that
includes some forms of feminism and that
includes you know the incel worldview
and all sorts of things so the thing
that we're really missing is a reminder
of the fact that I'm going to do the
caveat thing we talked about yes some
people are not heterosexual but for the
vast majority of people the single most
meaningful thing in your life is going
to be the relationship you have with
your intimate partner almost always of
the opposite sex right and we need each
other men and women need each other
we've been working together for
millennia and anyone who tells you that
your enemy is the opposite sex that
person is your enemy yeah that person is
your enemy that person is my enemy and
that person is our society's enemy um
they are destroying or attempting to
destroy the very building block of our
society that comes from both sides of
the advice as well the red pillar
spere teaches men that women
are adversaries to be of voided or
resources to be used and discarded those
are the only two ways and you know
that's black that's the entire
manosphere actually that's black pill
mgtow
incels pickup Artistry red
pill Sigma male all the way like the
full that's the the entire gamut for
anyone that doesn't know the memes
that's the entire mosphere of the
[__] manosphere and uh yeah there's
no one in there very very few people in
there who
say You're supposed to be a collaborator
with the opposite sex most of your
competition is intrasexual not inter
seexual men and women have worked
together for eons you need each other to
survive just because you've outsourced
protecting and provisioning to the
police department and the local
supermarket and you women have
outsourced the resources and uh the
company
to your ability to gain education and
employment and Netflix
like still broadly like we're not going
to be able to out technology ourselves
from the last 120,000 years of humans
being the way that we are so there's
more to relationship than dildo right
like you're not a dildo to your partner
there's more that you bring to the table
sometimes well I'm speaking for myself
maybe I'm I'm not sufficient in that
department but my point is let's frame
this in a positive way what is it that
we're trying to say what we're trying to
say is men and women need each other men
and women need to work together uh men
and women are not enemies uh that the
most powerful you are ever going to be
is with a good woman by your side what
do you say to the people that go this is
Trad pill nonsense like tradcon talking
point 101 like this is just another NPC
meme but coming from like someone that's
steeped in a type of relationship that
men or women don't need anymore well you
know how bigcoin is say have fun staying
poor have fun being a loser you want to
spend your life uh being unhappy with
the opposite sex whether you are a
feminist or one of these people go go
for it I'm not going to tell you how to
live your life but I don't think it's
going to lead you to a good place um you
know I'm I have male friends re who've
recently found their like soulmate or
their partner and they blossom they
blossom the moment that it happens uh
because we evolved to be together we
evolv to work together we evolv to drive
each other forward in really powerful
ways I would not I wouldn't be a tenth
of the man I am without my wife did you
read the post I put up a couple of weeks
ago about the [__] you family no I
didn't see that so [__] your money right
you're able to become oh I did see that
yes sufficiently financially independent
the money you don't need to do things
you don't want to do [__] you Freedom
you don't need to do things that you
don't want to do but then the final
stage I see amongst my male friends who
are you know 30s and 40s is the [__]
family which is a all that I
fundamentally care about in the end is
me and the people that are a part of
this nuclear pod
and everything else can go to hell
everything else can fall apart Jimmy
Carl has just sat in that seat he's been
through his fair share of like roller
coasters and he's been with his partner
like a decade and a bit like [__]
forever maybe even 20 like something
years and now he's got a son and a
daughter and yeah the coming home to
know that as long as that's okay as long
as that set and presuming that you've
stacked the [__] you money with the [__]
you freedom and then you had the family
on top it must be kind of similar to
being indestructive I'm still working on
the [__] you money yep still a long way
to go on the [__] you money the freedom
and the family the freedom and the
family yes uh and my wife and I we we
met by complete accident when we were 18
married by 20 and been together ever
since and the just on a very practical
like what did I get out of it level
it's it's been the single most
beneficial source of inspiration comfort
you know pick each other up when you're
down all of that
I I I I mean I admire people who don't
have that and still do lots of stuff in
the world but it would be so much harder
so so much harder um so again I'm not
telling other people how to live their
life I'm just saying this has been one
of the most tried and tested solutions
to various problems that human beings
experience throughout history we evolve
to be together uh and if it's a Trad
talking point then may maybe that's
right maybe maybe that some tra talking
points are correct getting back to the
masculinity conversation why do you
think it's so difficult for people to
publicly advocate for the problems of
men and
boys uh because victimhood doesn't work
for men the way it works for women we
don't feel sorry for
men and rightly so by the way rightly so
I mean biolog Ally men are disposable in
the way the women aren't for the obvious
reasons if you have a tribe of 10 men 10
women you send the women off to war
you're screwed you send the men after to
one comes back you can still replenish
the population so men are disposable
always will be much more than women uh
and so we we don't feel sorry for men in
the same way and I not advocating that
we feel sorry for men because I don't
believe that's a solution to men's
problems uh the solution to men's
problems is for men to be better what's
that mean it means you know what I mean
look at you this is what your entire
life has spent on bettering yourself
physically emotionally psychologically
mentally you're obsessed with
performance you're obsessed with being
better you're obsessed with being
happier more fulfilled all of these
things it's a pursuit of your own
greatness there are structural
disadvantages that are faced by men as
well right that very few people are
willing to accept at the moment
socioeconomically men are falling behind
education employment mental health we're
currently suicide awareness Suicide
Prevention Week in the UK the according
to one of the guys I was literally
talking to half an hour ago if you are a
man the single biggest threat to your
own life is
yourself you are more likely to die by
your own hand than by any other way are
you am I got suicide I've got suicide in
my family so I know but I don't think
you are the greatest threat to you
that's true but and I'm not the greatest
threat to me and why is that not
everybody has the same genetic
predisposition sure but you just said
you do and yet you are not the greatest
threat to you why is that because you're
fulfilled because you're are successful
because you're striving and achieving
because you have in life what you should
have in life uh the meaning and purpose
and the pursuit of a goal right and for
men this is one of the problems with you
know this mental health conversation one
of the reasons that men's mental health
is not as good as it could be is that uh
a we do live in a society which
discourages them from being men and
being the way that men are supposed to
be um but the other reason is that most
of the personal development um and
psychology fields are geared towards
female ways of being and most of the the
ways that we treat for example
depression men don't need the same thing
as women do when it comes to that what
men need is to feel powerful uh and
capable right the reason you don't you
are not the greatest threat to you is
that you feel in charge of your life
right and that's what men need to pursue
with every fiber of the being that's
what I mean when I say better uh you
need to struggle and you need to fight
and you need to achieve and then all of
this other [__] Falls by the wayside and
it's always been like this you know I'm
someone who's been depressed at points
in my life and it's not because I was
having a mental health problem it's cuz
my life was [__] and I was [__] that's
why right so what men need is to pursue
their dreams to fight and struggle and
to achieve there was a a point that you
brought up earlier on about how no
guidelines is liberating and terrifying
altogether and I think it's it's
interesting to talk about how there
isn't only one way to be a good man but
there aren't an unlimited number of ways
either and the problem of breaking open
the expectations around men means that
guidance for men and boys also largely
dissipates I had this conversation in
Qatar and the guy I was debating had
this conception of the man boox and he
said if you're inside of the manbox it
can be constraining because he was a a
member of the LGBT community Kuwaiti
American grew up in the Middle East and
wanted to be a dancer as a boy I'm like
I imagine it's pretty [__] difficult
for you to find a manbox that fits that
conception of you in it sure but if you
completely blast it open and you can be
anything want to be there's no
guidelines at all there's no guidance so
how [__] hard is this going to be you
got to you got to reinvent from first
principles what it means to be a man and
I you've heard this from Mary Harrington
and Lise Perry
but a lot of the guidance that was given
to men previously around chivalry it is
simply a difference of degree not a
difference of kind to go from men should
hold the door open for women and make
sure that she gets to the front door
safe at night to you shouldn't hit your
wife M it is one single thread between
those which is women are more vulnerable
and should be protected right lovely
conception that Mary in classic Mary
style
said the bouro rules that benefited
women who had had a partner that grew up
in a two parent household that went to
some highfalutin institution was around
people that had good good male role
models yeah sure you can break open the
of chivalry and maybe pay for the first
date or maybe you can drive yourself
home or get the taxi on your own or
whatever it is because the environment
that you're in is largely very
different the guy that grew up or the
the woman that grew up in a relationship
with a man who comes from a single
parent household whose mom or dad was
addicted to alcohol or drugs or there
was multiple partners coming through the
house they never got taught not to beat
your wife let alone not to hold the door
open and like the rules for thee but not
for me it's like the rules rules for us
protect everybody not just me and yeah I
I think it's a really interesting frame
to think about where the cultural
changes come from a lot of the time they
come top down but the environment can be
so different that getting rid of
something that seems quite innocuous up
here can actually Cascade down to the
bottom and the same thing goes for this
tyranny of the minority again absolutely
there are people that will be outside of
the manbox and maybe we should expand it
so that they can fit in it but if you
blow the doors
open where's the guidance like what does
it mean and this is also a consequence
of luxury beliefs which is Rob
Henderson's term I'm sure you've had him
on the show um and the the principal
luxury belief of our time is there's no
difference between men and
women that's a luxury belief there are
people who can afford to have it but
most people can't afford to have that
belief and then all else follows from
this uh because if you accept that there
are differences between men and women
then men and women should act
differently and that also means that
it's okay for men to be men and it's
okay for women to be women one of the
things that I find really [__] weird
man since we had our son is people will
go to my wife oh you're just you're just
at you're just you're just at home and
I'm like what do you mean just at home
are you [__] insane she's she's
raising our
son and and providing everything that we
need as a family and that you're calling
that just a thing so but but a lot of
women will judge other women for just
being at home yeah and actually I think
it doesn't apply to everybody caveat but
for most women the greatest gift their
partner can give them as opportunity if
they want to be at home with the
children to do that about 80 85% of
women say that being a stay-at-home mom
is an opportunity that an option that
they aspire to have yes and financially
for most people it's very difficult yeah
right now so it's it's it's the greatest
gift and so it's not just like men are
treated badly or women it's it's this
whole dynamic hurts everybody um and so
men and women need to work together uh
dads need to be involved in their kids
lives these are some yeah they look
they're Trad points one one if that's
what you want to call them but it's what
works it's what works for the kids it's
what works for the family did you read
the uh men are lost can we find a way
out of the Wilderness article by
Christine Ember who's in the Washington
post a couple of months ago was
Washington Post in there something
anyway she had this beautiful conception
in it that said um many young men feel
their difficulties are often dismissed
out of hand as whining from a patriarchy
that they don't feel a part
of it seems like a lot of modern men are
being made to pay for the sins and
advantages of their fathers and
grandfathers and I thought that that was
very interesting that um kind of like in
comedy right you're allowed to punch up
but you can't punch down and because men
have had it good for so long you have
this this concern in giving them any
sympathy and even though
largely pick most of the extreme
negative outcomes that you want in life
apart from sexual assault and it's
you're going to find a man on the
receiving end whether it's homelessness
drug addiction violent crime mental
health being in jail suicide like all of
it and there was this video of
um uh I think it was a TR 's man so
woman who became a man or looked like a
man or whatever who was absolutely
horrified by the lack of attention oh
people crossed the street when they were
walking towards it wasn't even just that
it's just like people ignore you when
you're a woman you get
attention and people just ignore a guy
most of the time for most intense and
purposes but that's you know those are
in my opinion in radical differences
between the Sexes the way the our
biological roles are
when women are going to get more
attention I think you can definitely see
like listening to your like pull
yourself up by your bootstraps kind of
mentality especially when it comes to
men you can definitely see that sort of
Soviet like man be hard man lift thing
man protect woman like I that was
actually money andth but that's that's
the best rush you get out of me um yeah
I I I think that you can see that and
this is why you know there's a
multiplicity of opinions about how to do
this and I think it's why it's
interesting that everybody can
contribute you know in it okay give me a
critique of what I'm saying I'd love to
explore that with you no but there's
nothing that I would disagree with
massively I think that it's important to
recognize the structural disadvantages
faced by men and boys at the moment
going from a brwn based to a brain-based
economy when you have a disposition to
be less conscientious where you are put
into an education system that doesn't
suit the disposition of boys but you're
graded in the same manner as an entire
sex who does
boys are naturally going to fall behind
and I think that you're seeing the
outcomes of this in the way that
schooling and between the ages of 21 and
29 women earn a grand and a bit more
than men do right the the the gender pay
Gap isn't a gender pay Gap it's a mother
pay Gap right that's the the the
penalization comes to mothers I don't
disagree with any of that but the
question is what's the answer what's the
solution to that I think that creating a
positive view for masculinity creating
and this is again why you know Peterson
and Andrew Tate as well have been so
successful because they said you can be
something you can actually step out
there and Wrangle the world and I
believe in you and I'm proud of you and
it's not wrong for you to try and want
to get Mastery or conquer something or
achieve something have ambition to be
able to make decisions easily and stand
up well under pressure like you know
these are all [__] good things that
are not only good for you but they're
good for the world as well I think that
there needs to be a positive Vision that
would be one I think that that creates a
positive feedback loop for men I do
think that there's some Manning up in
the most transcend and include uh like
wilan way that we can but I also think
that you know we need to look at
structural initiatives that can help
boys and men because there's no other
group on the planet who when they fall
behind are pointed at and said this is
your problem you need to sort it out
every other group we would spend
billions in taxpayer funded money to
create committees and Charities and
initiatives that actually work out
what's going on and help them boots on
the ground to be able to do this I don't
think like if a man has a problem or if
a woman has a problem we say what can we
do to fix Society if a man has a problem
we say what can a man do to fix himself
now maybe that's the fundamental
asymmetry at the heart of the sex
difference but in a society that has
Surplus resources that can help I don't
see why we wouldn't afford the why we
would make men unnecessarily swim
upstream if that makes sense it does
make sense however I think
that my view is what you said earlier
it's the fundamental asymmetry between
the Sexes now it's true that all groups
face various structural inequalities for
example I'm 5'9 barely and do you play
basketball not very well I should say
for for for that reason alone actually
if you look at the evidence High ism is
one of the biggest openly available
forms of discrimination that isn't
condemned or dealt with in anyway and
one of your team is scous so that must
be he's even shorter than me awful yeah
yeah so what's the answer to that my
answer to that has not been to get leg
extensions uh or to complain about
structural heightism do you know that
like structural heightism
you you joke but if you want to play
this [__] game this is my point I'm
not laughing at that I'm just it's
structural heightism is a term that I
haven't heard so if you look at the CEOs
of the top Fortune 500 companies like
90% or something like don't quote me on
it you can look it up like a very very
very significant portion of them are
over six' tall almost always the taller
president wins I think as well right now
is the answer to that not in Russia by
the
way in the you don't need so is Do We
complain about that should we complain
about that should I sit here and be oh
because I'm 5' N I don't get
the it doesn't help anything it doesn't
change anything right and I remember
it's so funny because I have a a friend
of mine who's like a green Party voter
voter the the most woke person that you
could possibly imagine and he's like
55 and I made this point to him I said
yeah but you you know you talk about
these structural issues with like this
group and that group and whatever and
you're 55 did you know about you know
hitis and whatever and he was like yeah
but being 55 has just made me who I am I
like yes yes you are what you are the
world isn't going to change to you right
my favorite scene in The Game of Thrones
have you seen Game of Thrones is Tyrion
when he's talking to Jon Snow and he
calls him a bastard and Jon Snow takes
offense and he goes have I offended you
bastard he goes let me give you some
advice bastard never forget what you are
the world won't wear it like ARMA and it
can never be used to hurt you that's the
answer to all of this right and you're
right about Peterson and Tate who I
think very different figures but
nonetheless their success is based on
the fact that they're telling men what
men do need to hear in that respect
which is it's okay to be a man it's okay
to have drive it's okay to have ambition
it's okay to have aggression it's okay
to want things it's okay to want status
it's okay to want money it's okay to
want Power these are all things that are
okay they have pathological side effects
when not handled properly but the drive
to achieve the drive to succeed the
drive to dominate the drive to win these
are good things and pursue them and by
the way here's the interesting bit those
woke
women they love that
[__] this is what I'm going to teach my
son right whatever the society tells you
about how it's wrong to be a man at the
end of the day they're all going to
reward you for being a real man this is
the best time in some ways to be a real
man cuz you clean up the competition is
is outing itself is taking itself out of
the picture if you act like a man you
clean up that's the position we're in
well there's a number of uh left-leaning
women who are lamenting the fact that
they can't find a man who meets both
their political preference and also will
woo them appropriately on the on the
date right it's like why are all of the
men who do the things that I want from
the other political party I think it's
like 30% or 40% of Democrats and
Republicans fear that their son or
daughter will marry somebody of the
opposite political belief so you know
this tribalism that we spoke about
earlier on speaking about toxic
masculinity as part of that debate I did
a little bit of preparation and I found
some of my favorite headlines of things
that are toxic masculinity mass
shootings gang violence climate change
the financial crisis is toxic
masculinity brexit the election of
Donald Trump not wearing a mask eating
meat physical fitness fast food
capitalism is toxic masculinity and
communism is toxic masculinity hip hop
smelling of Axe Body Spray which is
linkx for the British people being stoic
risk-taking religion but also secularism
and Atheism playing board games being
interested in cars and saying hello or
have a nice day all toxic masculinity
say hello is [__] atrocious m is
it yeah the that's sort of I think
that's part of the male gays you know
there was this um I think it was a rule
was it not put on the London Underground
for a while that like the men's like
wandering eyes are something that was a
concern but here's another thing right
I'd be interested to get your take on
this I brought this up with that same uh
Fitness influencer a couple of weeks ago
Sarah really good response as
well internet incidents big
ones people in the real world use the
response of the internet they
crowdsource their sense making to how
other people responded so you'll have
seen these gym Tik toks of girls
videoing themselves working out and
sometimes there's a guy in the
background and if the guy looks over a
bit much because for whatever reason
he's looking at her he's looking at the
camera he's looking at himself he's
doing whatever sometimes they make a big
song and dance about it the first big
one of those that
happened it could have gone either way
you could have tossed a CO and I would
have said I don't know the internet may
say that this is reprehensible I didn't
I thought it was fine but I could have
seen the internet going on the other
side of the fence and saying yeah sure
should find this guy like docks him
shoot him blah blah
blah it didn't and that now has created
a
new uh bar of behavior expected Behavior
both for men and for women the
interesting thing that it made me
realize is the women who saw that Tik
Tok had it have gone the other way and
had it have been completely
reprehensible and and totally not
allowed would then have reset their
worldview expectation
way more sensitive their radar is now
looking for did that guy glance over
three times or more in the space of 90
seconds if so this equals a dangerous
situation because the internet told me
so and it's a a very sort of slippery
slope in One Direction only it only
moves towards more sensitivity not more
robustness right I thought that was
interesting perception is projection
what's that mean it means that you see
what you you expect to
see you perceive your own projections of
the world uh you had that [__] hyper
viral moment about the scar makeup tell
tell it again for the people that so
they did an experiment where they told a
group of women that they're going to put
scarring on their faces or visual
disfigurements of some kind and then
they would go in into an interview and
the purpose of the experiment is to work
out whether the interviewer is going to
treat them differently because of their
phys facial disfigurement what they
didn't tell the women is as they were
leaving to go for the interview they
touched up their makeup and without
showing them the F facial disfigurement
removed the scarring so they went into
the interview thinking they're facially
scarred but they weren't and they came
back reporting massive levels of
discrimination specific comments that
the interview had made about them that
they perceived so you you you see what
you expect to see this is why teaching
people victimhood is so dangerous
because it makes them victims it makes
them expect certain things and then they
will react differently I mean you know
police interactions are a good example
of this if you expect that the police
are going to treat you badly because of
who you are you're going to act in a
different way and therefore cause more
problems and I say this to somebody you
know I was a very angry young man and I
and my wife used to piss me off so much
she would constantly say like I'd get
into an argument with somebody and I'd
be like that guy's a prick he did this
and she'd be like you are creating those
situations you know that right and I was
like no you and it took me like a good
10 years to work out absolutely I was
ABS [__] lutely I was right so we we
perceive the things that we put out into
the world and this is you know Peterson
talks about this is you can't see
without hierarchy because your brain has
to know what to focus on and what you
focus on is a function of the filter
that you project onto the world I'm
focusing on you now instead of the
bookshelf behind you I could have been
sitting here picking out a good book
this entire time it's been a waste but
so that's that's what's happening there
but it's interesting I mean I said
something at the time I was like look
these creepy men need to stop staring at
women in gyms otherwise they're going to
stop wearing lingerie to go there and
then when everybody
loses and and what I'm the point I'm
trying to make is that like you
know this is a very I'm going to say
something very controversial here Chris
you ready men are attracted to
women
I've heard about that let's sit with
that for a moment I've heard about that
so you know this idea
that you're going to be barely clad and
men aren't going to notice that yeah
sorry that's that's not what our brains
are for learned our brains are for
looking at your ass that's what they're
for that's what they evolved for I know
it's crudely put I learned the term for
this new style of Jim Short it's got
what's called a butt scrunch right have
you seen the butt scrunch yes right yeah
you're a married man online of course
yeah someone showed me a photo I tried
to look away um yeah it which is for the
people that haven't seen it and aren't
training in gyms with like 20y olds in
it's like a normal pair of shorts
training shorts for a girl like kind of
tight but then it's got kind of like a
thong bit that separates the ass cheeks
out um which has been normalized very
quick do you remember when do you
remember the first time that wearing
just leggings became a thing because I
do because it wasn't when I went to UNI
so it was after 2006 it was after maybe
it happened while I was at Uni so maybe
before
2010 but I remember thinking wow that's
like that's like everything on display
that's kind of like kind of like no
pants yeah but then also kind of not and
then now it's like oh that's kind of
like no pant well like that's kind of
like just a thong but blue or like
purple or Lil I feel you've dedicated a
lot of time to describing this
accurately which I appreciate I'm I'm an
casual ornithologist on the side um I
wanted to tell you about this can I can
I say something just on that before you
move on because I think we we sort of
like we're we're trying to pretend
things all the time
which yes men shouldn't be pigs right we
can all agree on that but in order to
not be a pig I first have to see your
ass that you've shoved in my face right
so I see it I am then after that not a
pig right but I see it and it's there
and there's my brain isn't calibrated or
designed or evolved I mean the the sole
purpose of our genes is to reproduce
right how is that you see what I'm
saying well there's a female frame
that's placed around this conversation
specifically that I don't think
fully maybe go as far as to say like
sympathizes with
the male brain reward system there is an
inbuilt reward system that men have for
looking at sexually gratifying objects
even things like two rocks that look a
bit like boobs right right what's the
first thing a boy does when he gets a
calculator WR
boobs yep now is that because of toxic
masculinity or is that because men
evolved for millions of years throughout
evolutionary history including preum
animals to seek the opposite sex and the
drive in males is just overwhelmingly
strong now once you have
noticed that how you act is where
culture and society and civilizing Men
comes in right just because you saw
someone's ass doesn't need doesn't mean
that you allowed to go and stare at it
or grab it or whatever but you saw it
and you're
not it's it's almost like it happens and
then you're like okay I need
to [__] yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah that's
how it works now what do you want me to
do about
that what are you supposed to do about
that I'm open
suggestions blinkers blinker
men big some people would be in favor of
that big Veil that goes over the top
right little bit of inside baseball for
people who aren't familiar with what's
going on in the podcasting world and
apparently this one's slipped by you as
well Theo Von and other significant
podcasters allegedly defrauded of
approximately $4 million and then calls
out the fraudster in a
video in an unexpected turn of events
Colin Thompson the man who is working
under cast media and with theovon is
accused of orchestrating a fraud
operation that cost Theo Von's podcast
this past weekend and potentially other
podcast an estimated $4 million theovon
and his crew detected inconsistencies in
their payments which is when trouble
started advertises allegedly paid Colin
Thompson and cast media directly leaving
Theo with less money than anticipated
and I know from my side of the fence
that there are quite a few other
podcasts that were with this particular
company and it seems like this gentle
gentlem man has been living a good life
meanwhile he's been robbing Peter to pay
Paul to keep on cycling this through
photos of Lamborghinis and nice houses
allegedly and people aren't happy and
then Theo did a 10-minute video that uh
said sorry brother you messed with the
wrong rat and this video I think within
24 hours it hit a mill plays photos of
the guy all the rest of it so ruction
ructions in the podcasting world I can't
wait to be able to be def frauded of $4
million that's my dream goal to get to
that
position [__] yeah you got to be careful
man you got to be careful that's why
what we're building trigonometry and
we've got some big plans Beyond just
trigonometry itself is um you know
bringing cool people together but doing
it under our own steam under our own
umbrella having everything managed by us
with the right values and the right team
uh it's really important yeah for the
people that don't know how podcast
advertising works it's I handle almost
all of my big Partners as well directly
but a lot of the time there'll be an
agency that sits in between you and them
invoicing is kind of hard oh there's an
IO and did the deliverables get done and
how many numbers did that podcast hit
and so on and so forth and also who's
advertising at the moment oh there's a
new company in town maybe we can
increase the the costs or the the price
that we're charging for this all that
like it's messy and it's back and forth
and whatever whatever especially if
you're doing lots of little deals as
opposed to how I have it which is a
small number of larger partners and uh
yeah you have these guys that sit in
between you and them classic agency
model it's like a modeling agency right
like you have a model there's your
talent you have clients that want models
and you take a bit off the top take
somewhere between 10 and 25% depending
on who the partner is and how big the
deals are but they hold the money like
they get paid the money from The
Advertiser and then less they're cut
they'll pass it down to the podcaster
these podcasts are largely run I mean
you'll get your YouTube AdSense Revenue
which is not nothing but [__] hell
it's not what you're making from your
proper partners and uh yeah if I don't
know man I mean it's such a it's
obviously you can chase these people
down for like we're going to [__] get
him for fraud but he's just going to
declare bankruptcy or [__] move to
the Cayman Islands or whatever
so yeah I feel this is the first time
that we've seen a big case like this
which is
slap bang in the bullseye of the anal of
of our world right it's the first time
that this has happened
and it's kind of surprising it hasn't
done before but hopefully it's a
formative experience that that's one
other
thing if you want to [__] some people
over for $4 million don't [__] people
over that have a combined reach of 20
million YouTube subscribers you know
what I
mean absolutely no it's not a smart move
uh but look I I I think we're sort of
living through a wild wild west of of
the internet I mean actually the wild
wild west of the internet is over but
the podcasting world it's it's very new
so there's going to be a lot of this
[__] going on I imagine this isn't an
isolated incident actually um so yeah I
think we all got to be careful and smart
about how the way we build we build
things that we build rule BR britania
rule
britan rule britan you're actually
British unlike me I'm trying rule
britania at last night of the proms
hijacked by activists waving EU
Flags the sight of hundreds of European
Union Flags the last night of the proms
have prompted an outrage from brexiteers
and a call for the BBC to investigate
those waving the EU flag in the Royal
Albert Hall appeared to outnumber those
waving the Union flag at the event which
is usually a patriotic display following
a campaign by pro- Europeans the
spectacle of so many EU flags being
waved as the whole belted out rule
britania provoked disgust from leading
Euros Skeptics what's going on
I I voted from the guardian I voted rain
in the
referendum and I've
largely I don't know if I've changed my
view of that how I would vote but my
view of that issue has evolved so much
precisely by seeing these [__] morons
who just completely incapable of
understanding what democracy means
democracy means that when you lose you
accept it there's some other Parallels
for that particular statement
when you lose you accept it and we've
had for the last seven
years these just absolute [__]
lunatics running around acting like what
democracy means is they always get their
way and they have to insert this into
everything they've just become obsessed
uh and
it's it's mindboggling to me how how
we're still talking about brexit is
mindboggling to me I I I don't get it
yeah that's insane it's insane that's
like a eon's old talking point now I
think if you were still talking about
brexit your brain is broken when do you
think that rule gets applied to
coid I think that with coid I actually
said this before coid was over and it in
this instance I get things wrong all the
time but this was something it turned
out to be right that people will want to
forget very quickly and they have done
even I want to move on from Co we talked
about it earlier but I don't have any
great desire to talk about it most
people have moved on without learning
the lessons of the thing so I think the
reason to still talk about coid is that
there is a future pandemic coming and we
ought to learn the lessons of this one
while we still can with brexit it's a
political decision that is not
reversible unless you have another
referendum which in which case you free
to campaign to have another referendum
if that's what you'd like I'm not sure
showing up with EU flags at the proms is
the way to achieve a second referendum
just I'm not political expert but that I
there is a like a Resurgence of activism
occurring at the moment but it's always
in criticism of stuff yeah so George
Mack one of my friends highlighted that
the last time that there was a ticket
tape parade for someone that wasn't
healthc Care Professionals in America
for something not against something was
Nelson Mandela in the '90s
so you
have a
culture of activism and of public
displays
of
passion however can only be against
something or people are only choosing to
do it against something and people
respond to incentives what's that um
saying ever great every grae cause
begins as a movement becomes a business
and eventually degenerates into a racket
and there are many people in this
country who made a career out of being
prominent remainers and when brexit was
over what are you going to do so they
just carry on and the people they feed
this crap like having this crap fed to
them so they just they keep going it's
it's a it's a reward incentive based
system because
it's a pointless conversation you're not
going to change the result of the
referendum even if you succeeded in
proving the brexit was a bad idea it's
already happened so you can argue for a
second referendum or another referendum
if you want but that's it right but
talking about how [__] brexit is isn't
about achieving a result beyond your own
personal enrichment satisfaction status
Etc and and you know FEI this Marina
perkus woman there's a [__] ton of these
people on on Twitter whose only thing
that they do is talk about brexit and
and get you know thousands and thousands
of views it makes me sad to think about
people
who I don't know there's like one
incident that occurs especially like
public stuff like some catastrophe or
news story like people that are still
talking about meline mccan do you know
what I mean like I understand [__]
terrible situation but there are people
whose entire lives I want I mean they
are her parents uh
uh I once stepped
[Laughter]
into [__] sake
constant it was there you left an open
goal it had to be yeah you can take the
comedian out of Comedy
um I once descended I got hit with the
[__] like blast radius of um
these two investigative journalists I
had them on the show when The
Disappearance of mine maccan came out on
Netflix and these were the two main
people husband and wife and I brought
them on I thought [__] hell like
these are the two these are the [__]
experts these are the guys that Netflix
went to they must be like [__] legit
you
any brought them on turns out there is
an Ardent [__] group of people who
really do not like them on the Internet
and I was a part of like meline McAn law
for a couple of weeks because this guy
has platformed these people that we know
they're a part of the like whatever the
[__] cover up scheme and they didn't
know the thing that went on do you
haven't read the original police report
from Portugal or wherever she was
from and it's there's part of me that
thinks like noble cause you're chasing
after it it's part of me that thinks
holy [__] you've been captured by this
one thing like this one incident has
just completely controlled your life for
forever I mean the one thing that
doesn't get said often enough is you
know there's a certain proportion of
society that's not mentally well
massively over represented online right
so I think a lot of people are just you
know it's it's it's an obsession of
theirs or whatever you don't get to see
what's driving this is what I often
think when I'm reading Twitter replies
CU I'm like well the these people are
like you know normal and right and most
of them are of course they are but like
you read something weird and then I sort
of like go okay let's imagine
what s of circumstances I would have to
be sitting in to write this and then I
see that picture and I go okay this
makes sense you know what I mean like
when I see people saying really crazy
[__] I'm like so this I I just think
what we forget sometimes is a lot of
people are you know in that situation I
was telling you about this preventative
medicine place that I've been to in
America so it's called Fountain life and
I did a podcast with the founder forever
ago and thought that sounds [__] cool
didn't really know what preventative
medicine was although it's kind of
encapsulated in the name and I ended up
getting like everything done full body
mrri CT scan heart angiogram brain
angiogram I need to do that man full
Works yes I will 100% link you in with
them one of the things they do I think
it's called
contrast uh so you're hooked up to an IV
which is uh like a mechanical IV so when
they press a button just [__] goes into
you so they've got you in the [__]
canul or whatever it is they've got the
thing in there and then there's this
huge big wheel spinning around you
unbelievably quickly so you kind of an
MRI machine it's a little bit more open
and this huge [__] off wheel that's
obviously like scanning [__] and then
this they pump stuff from this machine
into your vein and it lights up your
heart it goes into the um the ventricles
of the heart while this thing's in a
very specific position over you blah
blah blah blah but the felt sense of it
is Heat starting in your neck and going
only through your torso doesn't touch
any of your limbs going only through
your torso and finishing in like your
bladder and then it cools off around
your bladder for about 20 seconds it is
one of the strangest [__] experiences
it's not unpleasant strange not I would
definitely wouldn't even say it's that
unpleasant to be honest [__] it's like
must be what feeling like a dragon is
like just [__] heat moving around
inside of you so yeah that was very
interesting I can't wait preventative
medicine though we were saying it
before playing a game where you try to
catch up to a disease that's already
happened by Design is a losing fight
right absolutely no I I think that that
seems to me to be the future of the
direction that we're going is like
looking into genetic predispositions and
I know people who are having procedures
because they know they have a certain
risk Etc you know Chris Hemsworth found
out on that Discovery documentary that
he's got I think he's got um genetic
predisposition to Alzheimer's so he's
spending way more time with like his
family and he's doing other He adjusted
his entire life because I might not be
able to remember this should learn a
second
language that's protective against
Alzheimer's people who speak multiple
languages are much less likely to have
it oh I
wonder might might which way the causal
effect works I don't know but I imagine
exercising your brain in multiple ways
is helpful to protecting yourself
against things like
that yeah I I don't know man you know
there's a multiplicity of of
um ideas about how we're supposed to
live our lives and in some regards it's
amazing you know the promise of free
access to information 24 hours a day all
of human civilizations knowledge at your
fingertips that combined with the
falling away of The Gatekeepers and this
loss of trust in
institutions actually makes for really
[__] like disquieting Journey for a
lot of people because who do I trust do
your own research [__] I've got a Life
to Live I've got to try and to the
family and the kids and the house and
the dog and the me and and you want me
to I got to go and do my own give me the
medical journal I'm going to go through
this whether it's about health a Cobb's
good is sugar good what about should we
be eating more butter what about meat is
meat killing me or should I go vegan
what about paleo King says I need more
testicle like you know and it's
everything I'll see you and I'll raise
you which is what if the way for you to
live your life that's optimal is
different to mine right my wife's very
into arotic medicine and that's the
entire concept of it is the different
types of people that need different food
different uh different times that they
eat they all sorts of different things
um so a lot of it is experiential like
um I when I found out that you could
just eat protein and greens I was like
whoa this is amazing and that's what I
do I have carbs every now and again but
it it fits who how I am wired and my
wife is the exact opposite she's water
she's wind wind yeah you're fire I'm I'm
yeah I'm fire is the lead for me Anton
Anton's wind Francis water knew it
bloody bloody water pretty obvious water
yeah water is great if you can get it
off the
sofa then it it's like a ball rolling
down the hill you can't stop it it
becomes Unstoppable but it's a [__]
hard it takes a lot of fire to get water
off the sofa yeah I was fascinated he
taught me about this in uh in Austin
when we when we were hanging last time I
thought it was really fascinating you
taught me as well ambient water ambient
not not refrigerated water you should
avoid drinking cold water yeah too much
yeah yeah well just that's that's their
way that's how they say it and I'm by no
means an expert but generally ingesting
cold things is not good for you is what
yogurt I love yogurt so much though der
also not great as I understand I mean
look I'm not supposed to eat red meat
and I mostly red meat so you know you
break the rules sometimes yeah but no I
I understand what you mean that
different different sort of Strokes for
different folks but [__] hell like
even if there can be Different Strokes
for different folks I should be able to
find a source that can I'm this kind of
a person therefore I can do this kind of
a thing and this is
where if I was more
conspiratorial I would say that the goal
of a messy information landscape is not
to convince you of any one
narrative but to convince you that no
narrative can be
trusted and it seems to me that if I
was maybe even an nefarious domestic
actor wanting to make a sort of
nihilistic
fatalistic Placid com not compliant but
just like surrendered
populace well you know the rat
electrification experiment right where
they put a rat in this in a Cell where
the floor gives them an electric shock
and what they found was um in pychology
this is called what's the term Lo
helplessness yes this is the loan
helplessness experiment where if rat is
able to end the electric shock by
pressing a
button then the rat will continue to do
that if the rat has no control over the
electric shock it will just lie down and
take it right so I think this um you
what you're talking about is a system
that creates loow and helplessness in
people um which is one of the reasons
while of course it's super tempting to
bash the mainstream media and they
deserve a lot of the bashing we need a a
media ecosystem that's trusted we do
need politicians who can be trusted I'm
not happy with the status quo that we've
got at the moment where we trust no one
and with good reason but the solution to
that isn't to trust the mainstream the
solution is for the mainstream to become
trustworthy yeah um do you think that's
even possible I think it's very
difficult in the modern environment it's
very very difficult because um I just
see that us we're running a small media
organization to to you are too right
it's like do you get everything right do
you is your research always on point you
know so it's very very difficult
interesting what you said earlier
about um there are certain things that
they're able to do that we're not you
know like factchecking and stuff they're
also because of how they're incentivized
and subsidized and the
expectations like non-sexy stories you
know digging
into weather and accounts and stuff tell
me which YouTube channel is going to
predict tomorrow's weather no one right
not sexy enough too much of a cost to be
able to do and no one's saying the
[__] Met Office they're captured by
the woke although there was that thing
this year right where they made most of
Europe look like it had turned to Ash
because anything over 35 degrees celius
meant that it was like the blackened end
of a cigarette so maybe there is a
little bit incredible I mean [__]
going on yeah well there is a lot of
[__] going on what's interesting is
there's no I find the climate issue
absolutely fascinating it's genuinely
fascinating to me because the the
historical ignorance on that issue that
is being deliberately spread is is like
mind-blowing to me do you know the
Romans when they occupied Britain they
grew grapes on hadran's wall hadran's
wall for people listening is what used
to protect England from Scot from what
is now Scot what is now England from
what is now Scotland right one of the
northernmost points on the British Isles
uh now if you don't know Scotland
[__] cold it's average weather in I
used to live in Edinburgh for seven
years average weather in Scotland in in
August is like 18 degrees in rain at
best right
so uh the what we are being told about
that issue is absolutely mind-blowingly
incredibly unhelpful and inaccurate
wasn't the I think it's still around
somewhere in London or somewhere in the
South Coast 40 miles Inland from the
coast as ports pavy castle Yeah pavy
Castle you go there and they're like
Yeah The Sea used to be here I don't see
the 200 years ago yeah
so this whole conversation is very very
odd to me and uh after my Oxford speech
went viral I I had a lot of invitations
to go and speak to different people and
I I was talking to this guy who works
for the Indian government at a high
level and he told me when when India
became independent in 1947 average life
expectancy was 37 years old in India and
today it's I think
82 and that's because they burn fossil
fuels now are we saying to a billion
plus Indian people they're not allowed
to do that anymore do you know what I
mean like the way we talk about this
issue just it it's it's Ault it doesn't
make any sense it doesn't make any
logical sense the things that are being
suggested that we do don't make any
sense the way we're approaching it
doesn't make any sense it's it's
incredible to me the way this
conversation being had um and I and I'd
love to understand you know Eric who you
just had on he always says this like
we're lying about the climate for the
wrong reasons do you know what I mean
like it's like his point is climate
change is happening and it's a serious
issue but we're lying about the way to
deal with it and lots of other things
around it um that's one of the most
weird things to me about what's
happening like bjon
lomor during that oh my God Heatwave
we're all going to die kept posting
stuff about you know like actually the
number of forest fires is the lowest
it's ever been then the number of
hurricanes in America is etc etc etc and
I would love to know what's going on
with that [__] I would love to know you
got any
theories
um well one thing that's interested me a
lot is obviously people are familiar
with the concept of group think but
there's another thing which is um the
the abene Paradox I don't know if you're
familiar with it it's basically the idea
that people will often do things because
they think other people want them done
um and you combine that with mass panic
indoctrinating kids into being terrified
Etc and I also think human beings love a
doomsday narrative and a a portion of
the sort of side that I've been arguing
on which is this anti-woke side is like
The Barbarians at the gates now I
genuinely think that's true I think we
are undermining the founding pillars of
our civilization but there is an appeal
to that worldview
and if you look back neither of us are
old enough but in the 1970s the planet
was Cooling and everybody was terrified
of global cooling terrified terrified of
the population bomb absolutely now we're
terrified of the depopulation it it's
what we love we love to think and I
think there's a kind of like we live in
special times oh like a mass toyis yeah
like look look you know the last 200000
years you know [__] has happened and you
know you had Jesus you had World War II
and whatever but now is the real time
when [__] is happening you know and who
knows maybe it is happening U not on
this issue I don't think but yeah the
idea that we are living through a
climate catastrophe seems highly suspect
to me highly suspect but also somehow
very sexy very sexy now that's not to
say the climate isn't changing the
climate is changing but the question I
think we also ought to be asking is is
the climate changing a bad thing well
climate related deaths have decreased by
50 times over the last 100 years that's
Alex Epstein has he been on yeah we
haven't had him on but yes oh dude you I
mean you guys would [__] love him I'm
sure
uh he's an interesting dude yeah climate
related deaths have decreased by 50
times more people are killed by cold
weather than hot weather yes way way way
way more and we know that because this
is the thing about the idea of pursuing
that zero is it makes energy more
expensive that's the method by which you
achieve this to some
extent uh and tends of you know
pensioners freeze to death every winter
in this country now that doesn't seem
like a good thing to me I don't
making energy more expensive for poor
elderly people and them freezing to
death on their own in their homes in the
winter I don't think that's what I don't
think if we were setting out to improve
the world that would be one of the ways
that we'd do that but because we're
trade-off denialist because we refuse to
understand that actions have
consequences good and bad um we ignore
that uh and this
hysteria it's cult-like and it it it's I
find it very strange I find it very
strange whatever you think about the
climate is in and of itself our response
to it is strange people are just looking
for a cause yeah right and this is why
Co was so captivating on both sides
because it gave us a righteous War to
wage uh and again when you've got a
multiplicity of ways that you can go
with your life the man box has been
blown open nobody says that you should
be this to for masculinity maybe I don't
even need to get into a relationship I
can just boss [__] or like incel my way
through the next however many decades of
my life do all this sort of stuff ah
here's a single Vector along which I can
move I'm no longer in an open field I'm
on a set of railway tracks and yeah you
know Peterson had the ordering chaos
like Paradigm out there uh it feels like
there's a [__] hell of a lot of chaos
and not a massive amount of order for
people and then the people that live in
chaos land and prefer that look at the
people in order land as tyrants and the
people in order Land look at the people
in chaos land as [__] vigilantes
and yeah it's it doesn't surprise me man
you know and this is where I said to
Eric I wish that I'd got Eric to watch
the Sam episode before he sat down with
me because it was difficult for me to
portray a three-hour conversation in 20
seconds but I don't think that those
guys are too far apart like Eric's
saying we've lost faith in our
institutions but we can't get rid of
them Independent Media is both
advantageous and not going away but we
[__] can't like Outsource our sense
making to them as well how do we live in
this new world what does success look
like in this regard I thought it was
[__] interesting look I think we
we're living in a this is a metaphor
that is overused but it's sort of the
invention of the printing press kind of
situation that I mean that caus two
centuries of religious
War so I think what H what the social
media in particular and the internet
more broadly has done it is as broken
our ability to make sense of the world
and we are all reaching for a way to do
that I think it's going to take some
time uh and it's not going to be without
consequence um you know and I it's it's
interesting because the argument about
free speech is made very complicated by
the existence of social media because
there are people who say they're free
speech
absolutists I've never called myself
that because I don't believe anyone is a
free speech absolutist what what's your
conception on Free Speech Give me the
give me the framework well think about
this so Elon Musk says he's a free
speech absolutist he buys Twitter and
then the moment people trigger his
personal preferences he shuts that
particular form of conversation down
right when it was about children or
something like that right spreading
something it was I think you said it
about Alex Jones or whatever right
anyway my point is X Twitter whatever
has a moderation policy because it has
to it has to because the technology is
so
powerful this is the I'll give you both
sides of the argument right but the AR
argument for moderation as in content
moderation is that the technology is so
powerful if you can start an assault on
the capital or an undermining of an
election or whatever it is or a riot or
a a mass shooting or whatever if you can
start that from your phone the
technology is too powerful to be left un
uncontrolled uh and I have a lot of
sympathy with that argument however
let's flip it the other way
around you live in the United States
it's now a country for which I have a
tremendous regard and the history and
the formation of the country is very
interesting because it it it it creates
a country that is fundamentally very
different to every other country that's
existed
before do you get
1776 if there is
Twitter and it's
moderated I don't think you do because
who would allow a revolution to happen
you think King George would allow the
spreading of
misinformation right so we are stuck in
this place where on the one hand yes
free speech is absolute and is really
super important on the other hand
actually most people it's very easy to
be a free speech absolutist until you
are in the hot sea making the decision
and imagine you are in the hot sea and
you've got the CIA the FBI the heads of
government the whoevers your friends
coming to you and going if you don't do
something people are going to get killed
and they are going to get killed and
that's on your conscience it's up to you
right so
it's a very very difficult thing with
the power of the technology that we have
that has the ability to
multiply information narratives opinions
whatever in such to such an extent so we
have not worked out how to handle that
at all and everybody who says they has
they have a solution to it I'd love to
see them be in the hot seat for a day
and then we'll see how Absolut they are
about Free Speech or how Pro censorship
they are because there's a flip side to
the coin which is you do moderation
you're going to get accused of bias from
both sides y right so I don't have no
Envy for those people now I do think
they've made a [__] ton of mistakes I'm
just saying I suspect I probably would
have done too yeah Sam had an
interesting analogy where he was saying
if I spend five years building up the
waking up social media platform and I
want only Nazis to be allowed on it I
should be allowed to only have Nazis on
my social media platform or the inverse
I should be allowed to kick Nazis off
it's not my job to have people I don't
want on my social media platform and
this comes back to the like is it the
pipeline versus Public
Service argum I mean there's a very
strong counterargument to that argument
which is the one you've just made which
is once you've captured the entire
Market you're a monopoly and we regulate
monopolies for a reason which is uh to
be kicked off to be kicked out of the
local pub does not prevent you from
going and having a drink in a pub to be
kicked off Twitter prevent you from
communicating in that element of the
Public Square has there been any you
know there's there's usually concerns
around Monopoly has there been any of
that to do with online platform is there
such a big as such a thing as too big of
an online platform like [__] Facebook
and Tik Tok and and YouTube have got
like you know large portions of the
planet as
users so this is a new category in that
regard absolutely the banks got so big
that they need to be split up you could
take large things and make them into
smaller things right but you can't not
with this cuz no one wants to be on the
third best Twitter nobody wants to use
the third best Google right you do it
you split them off and then everyone
just converges back on which the monop
is what makes it valuable the fact that
it's on there is what makes it valuable
that's why Elon Musk bought Twitter
rather than building his own from
scratch yeah because he has the money to
build his own Twitter but you just can't
drag people over enough so the Monopoly
is the point interesting this is why
it's such a tricky thing a new category
yeah of business that's it's that's why
it's the point with with sort of
frictionless gravitation toward
whichever thing you want to choose to
use people will always Converge on the
biggest the best the whatever one
whereas yeah if Jim shark gets two and a
half billion
users or customers they say you need to
split up into gym and shark right or
Lloyds and TSB uh it's not quite the
same you don't have not everyone's going
to converge on this particular one there
interesting um one of the analogies I
used to use from my nightclub days and
Twitter's kind of like this in Nightlife
events it's one of the only Industries
where the other users of the product are
the primary value of the product itself
so if you ask one of your friends on
you're in your 20s mate how was last
night and they'll say mate it was
amazing so many girls in that club
you're hang no I asked you how your
night was I didn't ask who were the
other people that went to the event you
know you don't say why do I use an
iPhone I use an iPhone because David
Beckham's got an iPhone so I use an
iPhone because the camera and the apps
and battery life and stuff like that but
nightlife was very very interesting in
that way which is why it was so mimetic
to same reason why like I'll I'll open
this up to you internet uh some industry
Secrets here sometimes nightclubs hold
cues and sometimes they make the cues
thinner than they need to be so they
look really long and then they take a
photo because it looks like it was busy
we did that we did that all the time we
still do fresh as week next week in
Newcastle it's exactly what every single
nightclub will do but you have that same
thing with regards to the social media
as well the other users of social media
largely determine your experience on it
which is why you know Rumble is this and
Truth social is whatever right is there
a left leaning is there a left well they
had one masteron didn't they I don't
know what's happened to which tells you
quite a lot speaking of masteron I had a
guy called Ben Lamb on the show he's the
CEO of this company called colossal he
is using ancient genetic information to
bring the woolly mammoth back to life
within 20 years we will have actual
woolly mammoths walking on this planet
so they' found in the Arctic very good
for preserving DNA they found bones and
all sorts of other stuff uh Mammoth
carcass remains from that they've taken
I think it's maybe 40 or 50 different
because you don't get a full DNA
sequence in any one of them then they've
brought them all together used AI to
fill in the little gaps they're then
going to
implant a uh whatever it's called stem
cell pury poent stem cell inside of the
Asian elephant so an Asian elephant will
give birth to a woolly mammoth and then
after a sufficiently long amount of time
they'll get placed up north and they can
do all sorts of awesome stuff uh for
helping to fertilize the Arctic uh and
he also wants to bring back the dodo
bird the interesting reason he wanted to
bring back the dodo bird was the reason
that the dodo bird was killed off was
because of unsustainable uh hunting
practices so You' think that the mammoth
has like a a real function right the doo
bird kind people laugh at it for being
this stupid pigeon That Couldn't fly
away but maybe it was because of the
introduction of a particular a
particular like predator or whatever
yeah it might have been like ecological
imbalance that was done by man-made and
his point is Mammoth does a thing it's
like the the farmer of the Arctic dodo
bird is like a symbolic representation
of do you see all of the work that we
had to [__] go to to bring this thing
back to life be more careful when you
introduce invasive species into
different uh different ecologies I was
like [__] hell and he's super fired
up about it I found him really Charming
so I had a conversation with him the
other day I thought that was cool so
they're going to bring back prehistoric
animals I I think I remember seeing a
movie about that yeah I did say you know
how far back can we go uh real problem
bones bones and teeth don't hold much
genetic information which is a [__]
massive shame but we can do stuff like
uh sabertooth tigers like particular
types of saber-tooth cats um I was
asking him what else did he want to
bring back there was this huge [__]
sloth this massive thing it was like the
largest marsupial or they liveed like on
an island where there were no Predators
I think yeah this gigantic [__] sloth
so there's like a laundry list of
different ridiculous meapa prehistoric
an or prehistoric like deceased it's
called D
Extinction uh extinct animals that he
wants to bring back I just thought like
between that and preventative medicine
an AI and what's your thoughts on AI how
are you feeling are you uh [__]
scared that you're going to lose your
job to GPT 6 or I'm not scared I'm going
to lose my job no
um it's going to make a very significant
impact on the world but what that's
going to end up looking like I don't
think anyone really knows uh I think
there's probably there's a lot of fear
porn about it and it may be justified of
maybe I don't have any profound thoughts
about it I think um if you look at human
history people always use technology for
basically the same things right getting
laid killing each other Etc right so
you'll produce amazing porn you'll
produce amazing weapons it'll produce
amazing everything and then human beings
are going to do what they always do I
think is the truth right um like I
remember I think it was Desmond Morris I
I used to read a lot of his books I
don't know if you're familiar with them
but it's one of the things he talked
about he said like when you dig up a
clay tablet in Egypt from you know 4,000
years ago you read it is basically the
same [__] that we talk about now you
know my son doesn't call doesn't write
to me or doesn't visit me or whatever
it's you know Human Condition doesn't
change the tools we use to express it do
I saw a report from an ancient stone
tablet from I think Egypt or ancient
Rome uh that was a justification for why
this employee hadn't turned up to work
it was a sick note that he'd written and
it's this [__] elaborate story about
what happened and the wife and there was
the catastrophe and all this stuff and
yeah you do realize that human nature is
pretty [__] resilient yeah over a
long enough period of time but coming
back here's another thing I'll say about
the Free Speech conversation which is
that we haven't made nearly a an honest
enough case about Free Speech which is
why we're having a stupid debate about
it because no one wants to say the truth
which is Free Speech has consequences
that are bad what
like there are people who say atrocious
horrific [__] there are people who will
use the opportunity to be on a social
platform to mobilize and do Terrible
Things um now there's a big conversation
now about whether there's a lot of
anti-Semitism on X and actually there is
there is I have to block more people
than I used to have to block to uh on
Twitter but I am still in favor of that
being
allowed because I'd much rather these
people were in the open and people could
see what they are and they can have
their conversation instead of going off
into a kind of like a private place
where it's just them and the arguments
are never challenged so I think one of
the things people don't say enough about
free speech is yes it causes harm but
the Harm's worth
it uh and uh we don't make that argument
because it's too honest and you know
complicated and unpleasant and whatever
but the other side of the argument is
terrifying to me I don't think I've told
the story publicly but last time I did
question time uh question time is this
big discussion political discussion
program here in the UK um before they do
the show they do a warm-up
question that's not recorded and it's
not released so it's like a
warm-up and the conversation at that
time was Donald Trump had just been
unbanned on
Facebook and they was asking
whether was okay and they went to me
first and I was like look not that I'm
his biggest fan but I do think the
former or sitting president of the
United States should be able to speak in
public yeah I do controversial as that
is and then they went around the table
and whatever and then they went to the
labor woman who was there very nice
woman and she without batting an eyelid
went I think we should have the safest
internet in the
world and and what safer than North
Korea right this is come coming back to
this point about trade-off denialism
like they think safety doesn't have a
price and the other argument is freedom
doesn't have a price and the truth is
they both have a price and what we're
trying to find is the right point in the
middle between those two we want enough
freedom and enough safety and that line
is somewhere in the middle because if
you think about it that that's true of
any issue I can end murder outside of
the prison system
today I can stop murder wouldn't do you
and rape do you want to stop murder and
rape yes okay let's lock up all men
between the ages of 15 and 40 until they
age out of it you've ended
murder right but we don't do that why
not because there's a trade-off between
safety and
freedom and so it's the same of
everything and it's the same with free
speech you mentioned Trump what do you
think happens in
2024 I I'm not an expert on it but um it
looks like they're going to try and put
him in
prison and it also looks like he might
win is that possible yeah can both
things happen can you be president from
prison yeah you can be president from
prison yeah [__] off you can't be
president from prison look it up you can
be president from prison oh my God and
you can run from prison more
interestingly I wonder may maybe maybe
if you are I don't know maybe you can't
be president you can definitely run from
prison
maybe you get elected and pardon
yourself right so you're okay let's say
let's say that there's
no prison what what happens presuming
that everybody is a but why would we
presume that I mean I think it's pretty
clear that that's what's going to happen
oh okay it's the path that they're on it
looks to me like they're going after him
we just had Scott Adams on the show uh
and this is he said Trump needs to win
to stay out of prison that's what he
thinks um and I also think that the
other thing he said is like he actually
interestingly said that he thinks Trump
started this because when he talked
about Hillary and he said I'm going to
lock you up they were like oh oh you
want to play let's [__] play so I
think they're going after him now and
they want to put him in prison and I
think they will but you also think that
he I think he'll he'll win the
nomination for the Republic
yeah and then it's I mean who the [__]
look at the last election who the [__]
knows what's going to happen but he can
run from prison that much I know that's
[__] insane vivec ramas Swani playing
tennis with his top off whilst Trump's
in prison as the Trump ramas Swani 2024
[__] thing that looks like what it's
going to be right I think that's what
vivec's going for yeah he's angling for
it for sure yeah and who do you think
gets nominated for the Democrats well
he's got he's going to be Biden isn't it
I mean not going to abandon him
unless what he falls down a flight of
stairs yeah and in his case it wouldn't
even be a conspiracy it's just like who
do you think's the running mate any idea
no man look I let's be honest neither of
us is an well although you are now an
adopted American so you probably an
immigrant to that great nation I know
even less than you yeah uh you know I
try I the more I the more people listen
to what I say the less I try and talk
about things I don't know enough about I
mean that was a Douglas Mur thing he was
someone had asked
him about two years ago had asked him
why he hadn't written many articles he
wres like four five columns a week it's
like 3,000 4,000 words every week and
then his books and then his speaking on
top someone had asked him something
along the lines of why haven't you
commented that much on coid he says I'm
going to do something which is very rare
in the modern world which is to not
comment on something which I know
nothing about and I thought what a
[__] beautiful and outlier philosophy
to have but this is you know I see this
I see this allure in myself and you know
I have to check myself and probably fail
almost all the time at doing it uh you
people start to listen to you about a
thing or for a thing and you go well why
shouldn't I comment on the
Ukraine maybe my maybe my take on the
Ukraine
is useful Maybe maybe the world does
deserve to hear what my thoughts are
about immigration crossing the
channel and then you realize I mean I've
commented on both those things but
thanks mate but you are from the [__]
region of the Ukraine and immigrants to
the UK yeah right that's a lived
experience yes exactly uh I know exactly
what you mean your point is very very
very valid it happens with comedians
incidentally which is why comedians Pol
political opinions generally speaking
are so demented
because you stand on stage all day
making other people throw their head
back and admire you right or be
enthralled by you or whatever and you're
like oh maybe I do know something let me
give you my opinion about brexit it's
like no no just be the clown shut the
[__] up now that's why I don't do comedy
actually it's one of the reasons it's
like I always was I was more interested
in making a point than I was in being
artificially funny you know what I mean
um and I always thought of myself more
as a saturnist anyway which was a
different thing but yeah uh being in
front of a microphone imbus you with a
level of confidence that is very often
inappropriate right it's like
permanently being
on uh oratorial Viagra yeah if
everyone's listening to me I must be
worth listening to that's that's what
happens in your brain regardless of what
it is that I'm talking about regardless
of the format or the yeah I've got these
um these live shows coming up uh towards
the end of the year November mid
November um that's awesome thank you uh
what's your advice for someone who have
touring comic played [__] thousands
of shows across your career what do
people who haven't put that time in on
stage not know about how being on stage
works this is going to sound like a [__]
answer but actually it's stage time is
just like air miles on the clock like
with pilot you have to fly a certain
number of miles um but you know I always
think about you know whatever Charisma
whatever else it is it's really about a
comfort with yourself in front of other
people if you're and not everyone is
equally charismatic naturally but if
you're comfortable with who you are and
you are able to do that while you're on
stage or in front of a camera or
wherever that's that's the the the magic
ingredient it's like my favorite quote
is the most important thing in Show
Business is authenticity if you can fake
that you can do anything right
authenticity is the key ingredient which
is why I think you've been successful I
think it's why Joe is successful I think
it's why Francis and I have had the
success we've had it's I almost feel I
don't know if you feel this but the
longer we go it's like the more layers
of the UND and we peel off to reveal
more of who we truly are yeah I would
say so
because you become more comfortable with
things that you masked over before yes
there's you know
uncertainty
or like nerdiness I suppose like
necessary rabbit holes that you want to
go down and I've never had this before
obviously you had this and you may have
had it before comedy I don't know but I
never had a single Pursuit that I got to
go as narrow and deep on as I have on
having conversations with people and
when you really really start to [__]
like drill down into okay what does what
does Mastery begin to look like which
I'm not at but I can Glimpse I'm like
okay what does that actually look like
what does that feel like what does it
look like to make rules and then break
rules and then put them back in again
and do things I'm talking to some of the
guys now I want to start doing slightly
more um scripted bits as a part of maybe
some of our ad reads as a part of maybe
some of the intros um and that's like if
you actually look at that that's a very
inauthentic way of doing what is
supposed to be an unbelievably authentic
relatable medium we're taking the rules
from you know like sitcom Legacy Media
to try and apply that to this but I
actually think that that's breaking
rules that have been made and the reason
you can is because you've learned them
unbelievably well mhm right it's not not
knowing the rules it's disregarding them
purposefully yes and I'm just EXC I'm
excited by by all of the different
options and opportunities and and ways
that there's cool stuff to do and it's
[__] awesome to see what you guys are
doing at trigonometry the what I know
about what's coming that more people
will find out at some point over the
next however long is [__] amazing I
think that the UK
needs a nice movement a good
conglomeration headed by people who
understand this industry that can be a
platform for others who have amazing and
interesting things to say but don't yet
have the platform that they deserve to
be able to save them on well this is
what we've been working on for a long
time and I I can't quite say exactly the
people in who are going to be involved
other than to say they're going to be
[__] awesome uh but we want to use
the platform that we've built uh to to
make it so that trigonometry is the main
show on that platform but there will be
other shows with other people and me and
Francis interspersed with other
interesting funny hilarious clever
commentators Etc so rather than you know
two trigonometry interviews a week and
some raw shows and a bunch of we've
started doing a lot of scripted stuff
ourselves comedy uh you know my I re I
often record my substack pieces now and
we put them out as videos we we had a
couple of really viral ones one I did
about communist and fascism that you do
one about Jordan Peterson recently I did
yeah yeah that one's done very well
surprisingly um yeah so uh but also we
want to start thinking about how you
know I'm thinking about us now as a
media
organization that's my frame for what
we're doing want to bring other people
through help them make exciting content
that fits with the values of what we do
that's going to be entertaining for our
audience it's going to be informative uh
and grow it over time into a real hub
for awesome content um and that to me is
super exciting next phase with this
because I think the media industry uh
that we are in the New Media industry is
is going to change rapidly uh and one of
the things I see coming down the pipe
quite quickly actually is consolidation
uh this idea that you're going to give
five quid a month to your favorite 70
creators it's not going to happen the
admin alone will kill you right so
people are going to want a place and you
know obviously our politics are very
different but the model of the daily
wire I mean they've executed it
incredibly well I went to go and see
them I filmed on Brett Cooper's show
four five months ago something like that
yeah and uh dude it's a it's a machine
workshop for creating content yeah over
there's the merch Team all they do is
make [__] tumblers and designs for
t-shirts yeah here's an entire 3 by 10
row of editors all working away millions
of meeting rooms oh and here's an entire
different building with everyone's
studio in it and oh here's a control
center that allows us to edit anything
at any time and I found this out
[__] I'll check that this is okay to
say Shapiro has got some special [__]
landline thing some special type of
connection that runs from where he is in
Florida to where the Hub is in Nashville
that allows them to cut his show live as
if they were on site wow I didn't know
that and I've been in that studio a
couple of times now in in Florida well
I've so I haven't been to that one but
I've been to the pipeline where that sh
ends up yeah yeah yeah been there too
it's impressive it's very impressive
what they buil say what you want say
what you want but here's here's an
interesting thing for you two two
analogous stories that I'm sure that
you've thought about before the sort
of
slow dilution or [__] explosion of
The Young
Turks and PR of daily wi that in a you
know you're talking about congealing or
bringing together meanwhile a lot of the
groups and affiliations and
organizations you know IDW largely
disbanded that was like a loose
affiliation an organization though lose
affiliation of people Young Turks you
know you say the wrong thing slightly
and downstream from that some people on
the network don't agree with other
things that you've said you know like
[__] apparently bench buo was crowd
his first ever lawyer or some [__]
as as well and then you know they've
split off and Big C conservative and he
turns out that he bought the URL only a
couple of months after they spoke but
months before he announced that he'
recorded these phone calls and all this
sort of
[__] so I think that sometimes we're
too quick to try and patent match stuff
yeah and it's like oh all organizations
devolve into you know fractured
individual like groups or whatever all
you know power becomes centralized into
one thing it's like maybe it's just flux
maybe it's just Tides you know maybe
there's like es and flows and and and
stuff Happ well look I think you're
going to be able to continue to do what
you do uh whichever way you want to do
it I'm interested in bringing uh people
through who are very talented but who
basically what we had to do with
trigonometry and one of the reasons I
haven't made their few money uh is that
we have a big team as you do but we have
we've always had a big team because we
wanted to create the foundation for what
we're about to do um and so Francis and
I really don't make a lot of money from
it because we're investing in the future
and what I want to do is we've kind of
created a factory for making content I
want to bring people in who don't want
to build their own Factory but who are
very good as creators of making content
yes exactly I mean car Carl Benjamin
load he spanked it he's doing very well
they they're playing a game of Monopoly
around the [__] some like transport
police [__] somewhere in the country
and it's they're slowly taking up the
transport people have got the corner
office and got all of the ones on either
side Apparently one of the guys was
telling me that he had some incident
that had occurred at the railway line he
had some sort of stalker that followed
him at the railway line and because it
happened at the train station the
transport police had pick up on it and
he rang them and the guy rang him back
and he could hear him through the wall
he said mate should I just come through
opened the door and was talking to the
guy that was dealing with his case like
[__] hell that's interesting but yeah
you know this it's cool man it's cool
and it feels way more cool to see it
happen from Grassroots where you can
watch episode one of some horeshit show
thank you with terrible lighting [__]
Audi all over the place and no one knows
what they're doing ugly hosts ugly hosts
yeah that hasn't change and then you
work to the stage where you're like holy
[__] like I can actually see the full
trajectory of this entire thing laid out
in front of me as opposed to like oh
[__] rert Murdoch and is it part
Shady M shade face invested a nameless
[__] like hooded figures drinking
Adrena Chrome dancing around a pentagram
yeah yeah that's where we want to go I
understand no but closing uh closing the
loop on all of that I I just think this
is the next phase in terms of what we
started with which is let's stop whining
about how we've been cancel you know I
think it's it's been a thing of mine
which like we keep saying saying well
the mainstream media isn't doing this
then well let's [__] do it then make
your own mainstream media if if you
think that they're doing it wrong let's
[__] do it right let's do it uh and
let's see who wins that's the thing for
me is like I love the competition I love
uh attempting to build new things the
creating the challenge of that working
out how to run a business with [__]
immigrant mentality man man to me this
is the most exciting thing you know we
were talking with a good friends of mine
last night about how much money you need
to be happy and I was like and and
somebody said that the statistics are
$770,000 a year and maybe it's in like
$209 but whatever beyond that point it
doesn't really make any difference and I
was like well for me it does make a big
difference and then I thought you know
what what if I made a million dollars a
year which is way more than I make now
but I wasn't having the experience of
growing working with my friends all of
that and then I was like actually yeah I
don't think it is the money it's the
it's the doing it it's the creating it's
the building this is why of all the
people that I love to watch I love Dana
White interviews I was about to bring up
Dana White [__] I just I cannot wait
to interview him it's you got him in
America uh we are working on it so he's
basically he's open to it but it's just
about finding the right time as you can
imagine he's a busy guy yeah
um I [__] love that guy I love
listening to like I love the way he
dealt with Co I love everything about it
You' seen that clip it went super viral
a couple of times where he says bet
against me [__] bet against me tell
me it's not going to work I love that
[__] every single time man like that
energy I'm the same I really really
enjoy it and I think that it's missing I
think that there's not enough like
conquerors in the world of personal
development and
business there is from a performative
level but I don't look at Dana White and
think that he's saying what he thinks
sounds cool for people to hear no I
think he's speaking his Philosophy for
for yes which is one of stand on this
hill come and have a swing yes yes and
uh I've always been like incredibly
competitive I thrive on it I love it um
and look one of the things by the way
you've taught me I will say this is you
were the first British podcaster who was
in our space who when I've met has been
from a who had a growth mindset which is
why I said when we first started how
unsurprised I am by the amazing success
you having because you've always had
that attitude and it shows and that's
why you're successful and that's why
you're friends with everyone in the
industry you know I I just um I think
it's a natural cons your Success is Not
an Accident is what I'm saying at all
it's a natural consequence of the person
that you are and Dana why inspires me in
the way that I'm inspired by your
success as well because it's just like
this is a guy who got his friends
together they bought this thing for $2
million or whatever it was at some point
there were 30 something million in the
the hole and they just kept going until
they crushed it and there's a lot of
other things that they do very well I
think as a if you just switch on the G
the fights on the Saturday night you
wouldn't see but they they make it
entertainment they make reality TV shows
out of the content they the the way they
present the fights is like very well
organized and it's beautifully sharp
think about this way think about what if
you watch Boxing now how [__]
pedestrian unnecessarily ceremon
fing guy carries out a and dos and fuing
a list of 50 people who' donated money
to this thing we are here in the
presence of the The Bu the Nevada state
and the this this this you're like no
[__] just tell me the fight yeah show
me the fight give me the tail of the
tape get me amped up let them punch each
other and also uh what they've done
incredibly well is with boxing no one
gives a [__] about anyone on the
undercard or the card They just care
about the the headline fight y uh UFC
the headline fight May very often isn't
the best fight that actually happens on
the night they will be the best fighters
on the night but it won't be the best
fight so fight of the night will I would
guess only maybe 30% of the time go to
the main card yeah and it's just they
they and therefore they are building up
other Talent this is what we're talking
about with what we're doing they're
building up Talent who are not the
headline Fighters but you're seeing them
from an early star and you follow them
and you're like oh this person is
getting better and they're fighting this
guy and whatever so just from a business
perspective I am so inspired by that
attitude I think it's I love it and I
think we're probably going down very
different paths in that you've gone to
America where that attitude is prevalent
I'd love to take it every time I go to
America I Come Away buzzing but I'd love
to bring more of that [__] here that's
how I see our future sat next to
opposite step Bartlett yesterday and
said if I could gift the UK anything it
would be enthusiasm yeah you know
there's just so much enthusiasm in
America and there's [__] there also
stuff that they're super [__] at and I
wish TR I wish that I wish I could take
some of Britain to America as well I
went to LA man I spent three days in La
sort of in the kind of like
entertainment world you know doing bill
Mah and stuff around
that that is a different [__] world
my friend how so oh
it's I am not a religious person not yet
anyway but when I was there I was like I
can see why people need
religion this place needs God it [__]
does I'm serious man like the way people
think about other people like if all you
have is your success if your value
derives from your status and success
whoa that gets dark quickly whoo that
gets dark quickly [__] disposable
objects every oh man it's [__] the way
the way see people see each other is
there's no Humanity there it's just like
you're an object for for what I'm trying
to get to um and that was eye opening to
me it made it Hollywood makes sense to
me now the movies they put out make
sense to me now that I've been there a
lot of it makes sense in a way that I'd
never realized see I never realized how
powerful Hollywood is at shaping our
idea of what reality is because the
movies like we in in Britain we think we
understand America right because we
watch their their content that's why but
that's not the reality of America at all
and the more you travel around America
the more you are confronted by that fact
you know the more time I spend in the US
it it makes it makes me more right-wing
in the in the American conception of
like State's rights because I'm going
there's no I I had a fly from Salt Lake
City to LA and you get on the plane in
Salt Lake City and you arrive in La
which is not that far and you go these
are different [__] these aren't just
different countries these are different
worlds different Religion different
people different way of thinking
different philosophy different culture
different everything and the values are
completely different um you know America
is an incredible place um I'm really
enthused by it and there's also
tradeoffs to to to some of the way that
people are there as well so it's and
it's actually you know we talked about
masculinity and femininity and I think
um I actually know what people mean when
they talk about toxic masculinity and
toxic femininity which is you need both
you want to be thinking about it as
raising both bars at the same time if
you want to be a good leader for example
right you need to be strong and you need
to be able to say the thing that people
don't want to hear and make yourself say
the thing that you don't want to say
because you don't want to upset people
and on other hand you also need empathy
and compassion too like you want to be
raising both up and I see that the same
way as culturally I want to take the
best of the US stuff and the best of the
British stuff and meld it together into
into something really exciting [__] yeah
constant and kissing ladies and
gentlemen where should people go they
want to keep up to date with your stuff
uh the the best place to find my work is
trigonometry of course on YouTube and
the podcast and I write on substack
which has got really blown up at the
moment uh I'm excited about that as well
so on Twitter you know Constantin
kissing everywhere hell yeah Constantine
I appreciate you appreciate you my
brother thank you very much for tuning
in if you enjoyed that episode with
Constantin then press here for the
fulllength three-hour conversation I had
with Eric Weinstein